[music playing]
CUTTER HODIERNE: It's not
possible to get a Western film
crew into Iran at the moment.
So I've asked a local
journalist called
Afsin to search on my behalf.
[non-english speech]
I'm hoping someone will
recognize the victim's boat,
or better still, their faces.
CUTTER HODIERNE: This is a
potential lead, an Iranian boat
that disappeared off
the coast of Somalia
in the same timeframe
as the video.
CUTTER HODIERNE: There's only
a handful of Iranian boatyards
that use fiberglass and
wood to make their dhows.
And one of them is
based in Konarak,
a fishing port that
acts as Iran's gateway
to the Indian Ocean.
If the victim's
boat is from Iran,
it may have been built here.